You can't just go along
with what people are saying,
Susan, okay?
There's no
scientific proof,
no real evidence
of a ManBearPig.
Well, there's a lot of smart
people saying ManBearPig is
real.
Yeah, and a lot of smarter
people saying it isn't, okay?
What you need to understand,
Susan,
is that everyone has an agenda.
Okay?
Everyone wants to use
the fear of a ManBearPig
to get what they want.
(Glass shatters)
So they throw around
bad science, bad taxidermy.
(ManBearPig roars)
People coming out of the
woodwork
are now experts
on the subject.
(People screaming)
(Roars)
But you have to use
your own brain, sweetheart.
You can't just
let people tell you
that if you don't believe
in ManBearPig,
then you don't care
about the world.
It is real!
You wanna believe it's real,
you go right on ahead, Susan.
No, it's right there!
It's right there behind you!
(Man screaming)
(ManBearPig roars)
Okay,
ManBearPig is real.
What are we gonna do
about it now, huh?
that's gonna make
any difference now, Susan?
What?!
We have to do something!
What can we do that everyone
else will also do, Susan?
Come on, use your brain.
Even if we do something about
it... (ManBearPig roars)
...what about the Chinese?
They're just gonna keep
right on -- Ahghhggh!